hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly chacha every tuesday
at two p.m. pacific right here on
gamespot com I'm your host Daniel duardo
and by mr. Justin hey Walt howdy howdy
they do my friend doing good there's a
lot of news this week so there is I'll
join you guys what better person to come
on to tell us all about that stuff and
of course alexa ray corriea how you
doing hey I'm good how are you doing I'm
doing fantastic yeah I'm doing better
because I heard that a game that might
have gone missing the last guardian
looked like the trademark was getting
Sony hadn't like updated the trademark
and but then that seems that that might
be a clerical error I think you ever
think that it would actually be go away
like it oh yes yes point after e3 last
year when they didn't show at all
because everyone said oh they're showing
it off this year like all the web
whispers in the industry said it's
definitely gonna nada and then I thought
you know what maybe not and you could
use the great video last week with Mary
about sort of games that have dropped
off our radar I did um yeah there are a
lot of them that have dropped off our
radar actually the last guardian was not
included but they include things like I
think people forgot that there's a new
gears of war and development and cliff
bleszinski Project Blue Streak I think
we're going to hear more about that at
GDC he has a panel the shin megami
tensei Fire Emblem crossover the new
crackdown the new phantom does the new
mirrors edge there's a lot of things
that have sort of been announced and
then gone by the wayside have been long
stretches cyberpunk 2077 yeah The
Witcher 3 guys like where is that game
that was a really good trailer that was
an awesome yeah for something we've not
seen anything else up I guess they're
probably got their hands full at the
moment when I care with the witcher know
in just couple of months and a little
ass guardian it is kind of a weird case
because i remember when i almost when i
first started into video games like back
in two thousand eight that was something
that was announced and you know every
year they've renewed the trademark and
so a lot of people were scared for the
less guardian because suddenly Sony
didn't renew the trademark and it's
then we haven't heard about for such a
long time they were like well guess I
mean just cancel the Sun he was like no
no no they we assure you still in
development but that's literally all
we've heard for like the past three
years is we haven't seen anything new
it's just in development it way that the
you know the Fumito waiter who has
worked on the gate who's worked with
that studio for such a long time and is
the creative vision behind it his
basically said you know I'm done yeah I
contributed what I needed to to that
game and I'm out so now we're just like
is we assume is going to be a ps4 game
but literally nothing so is that not a
massive worry that like the clouds like
the reason people were industry
interested in the last garden was
because of the development clamp behind
it and then it just seems like maybe now
they have this name that has such an
attachment to it that they're just going
to push out something like years later
that won't actually have anything to do
with the like creative like like seeds
that are first started from it would be
such an interesting story to be behind
the scenes and dislike to see the drama
that must be going on there like that
has to be really great like I mean
stretched out now probably probably not
like day today is probably really boring
but like if you were able to convince it
now if you were to be able to do one of
those behind the scenes things but that
that happens to a lot of games sometimes
it really hurts them you know like a
Duke Nukem yeah absolutely long time for
that and switching so many studios where
as Sony for them they've kept this a lot
more under wraps like we really don't
know what's going on we haven't seen it
in different versions we don't know what
those changes have been so I mean it
could be any number of problems that
that have kept it from coming out but it
could also be because they're trying to
define the best way to bring it out or
maybe like what they came what they were
coming up with for ps3 didn't really
translate over to ps4 yeah it could be
really good now maybe well hopefully
we'll find out over the next five months
or so with GDC coming up in a couple of
weeks III though is when obviously we
see so many new game enhancements last
year there was absolutely tons of them
as some we've not heard of since like I
think your games like phantom dust
scalebound crackdown they've mentioned
them I know that a one of the Microsoft
producers has like gone on a couple
podcasts and been like oh like you're
going to find out more tea tree or like
scalebound is going to be like a
see our RPG but we haven't really really
know what scalebound is yet yeah and we
don't really know what the new crackdown
is yet we just have that trailer same
with the Phantom distribute so I think
III will be big for those three like
Microsoft is going to give us everything
we want or they can give right now for
those three surely some sort of years
the nucleus maybe maybe because they
release an update last year where rut
Ferguson shows like a concept art that
was blurred out so we know that they're
working on it maybe we'll get like an
announcement that'd be nice now that the
xbox one's doing fairly well I think now
would be a good time to announce it um
and that kind of thing doesn't mean that
those are in trouble I mean we in the
same way that movies like those you'll
see a trailer for something at comic-con
and that just means that you know
they're teasing it they're working on it
you really don't want to hear too much
more about it like sometimes seeing too
much can set of expectations or things
can change yeah I got a really good
example is bioshock infinite where we
saw a lot of that game in the lead-up
yeah and a lot of that isn't didn't get
into the final what's that first trailer
now it's like it's so far removed from
what actually came out they weren't able
to use those ideas like or they had to
use them in different ways you have to
scale back coming because of the reality
of making these games on these huge
budgets and last week as well we heard
about as something else that's going to
be happening at e3 and I'm very very
excited about which is that there's the
soft works are going to be having their
own lil Ubisoft EA style show and tell
and what games do you think might come
up in that it's gotta be fallout 4 this
is their first ever press conference
it's got to be fallout 4 we've have the
new doom that's in development right now
probably see more of that yes I was they
showed that was quite calm and last year
the Westies only people in the room saw
those are no one outside of theirs yeah
and I think I'm gonna jump out on a limb
and say that we're going to see another
Dishonored yeah it's a sauna suit could
show maybe a wet to the hot franchise
wet maybe those are the things you want
to bring out when you're gonna do your
own conference but do you think they're
going to do a full conference do you
think would be you know going the route
of Nintendo and doing a kind of video
directly yeah could be cool too I think
they have the the amount of like what
the Fez is now is like they're just
publishing so much stuff that they have
enough fans to like fill out a room and
like say this is everything we have like
if you be soft can do right now I think
like that says they're in a good place
to do it as well I'm kind of
with you I don't think they can do that
without announcing fallout 4 and like
the amount of ramp like rumblings about
it last year myself a 90 put out a video
last year saying like it's definitely
gonna be at e3 this year like there's
too many people talking about it and
then nothing I'm like I was absolutely
gutted but there's still like those
voices are so saying like what's what's
that team what's the skyrim team been
working on since then like they have to
work on something and good money's on
for that right this has to be it or it
could be a collectible card game you
know but it'll be matched three and
you'll have like little fallout heads
and i guess i'll have to wait and see
and III is on a couple of months GDC
though is on in a couple of weeks that
seems to be the time of year when all
those secrets like start to come out
yeah there's a lot of drinking in DC DC
is not is not an e3 level topics that is
it is the game developers conference
traditionally it's always been for game
developers but more and more it is a
place where people are showing off new
stuff and we know a lot of things like
they've been very public with some stuff
that's going to be at the show Steve's
gonna be showing off new steam machines
microsoft said they're gonna have a big
presence like there are going to be
games there which is that someone in
some ways takes away from the spirit of
what GDC is about but yeah it's really
exciting for us like especially since
it's right down the road it's right next
to us and a lot of people hang out
there's a lot of game developers and not
all of them are you know as as good with
keeping secrets yeah some others
sometimes you just walking around and
I'll just be talking about oh yeah
follow five is totally this awesome game
w bar did it go camp out in the WR the
doll really yeah that's really that's
where everyone goes to release their
secrets there you go and so if you're in
the san francisco area renter lee march
head to the TT bar and then you won't
have to listen to gamespot.com anymore i
can just get it all from the source
right there and let us know what you
think about the last guardian some of
those other games that we might see in
2015 in the comments below alright folks
we're gonna be back another second talk
about the order 1886 a game that i've
only recently learned to get the date of
right I've been calling it 1866 forever
as like some sort of a pre centenary
collectible british england winning the
world cup six stuck in my head yeah but
until then we've got the trailer for the
latest style
expansion pack for a total war I think
it's the 9th sound alone expansion pack
for this series of games it's a total
war Attila
the order 1886 nope nah the wonder of
these VOD segments is that we can just
cut that [ __ ] though so I can just start
from the start all over again I try to
god I've been gone 80 of these 64 like
what year were you born in nineteen 8888
I you don't have this problem are you
1966 you're born in nineteen sixties
again it's really funny here's a fresh
face [ __ ] I look young that's
amazing all right let's go back to much
let's go back to my single we'll try
that again thanks Mel jaws appreciate it
1 866 all right it's not live right
we're good good haigo haigo i fade up on
me the order 1866 that's out later this
week 18 1886 when I say 66 boat here yes
I said watch I said it right the first
time [ __ ] I blamed the bread English
ruining the world cup in 1966 bed a
black for the bike it again third time
third time's the charm 86 right all
right d I like the last right at the
start we gotta we gotta reset like we go
fade to black here we go it's okay we'll
fix it in post yep professional the
third came up I can't do it now it'll
cutting when the Third's there are we
got it the order 1886 is that later this
week on various computer game consoles
our review of the game will be up on
Thursday this week but today gets gotten
a bit of flak it seems some folks in the
UK put
puts Pedro a novice competing in five
hours Justin what's the deal a lot of
people have been concerned that there's
going to be a lot more to watch in this
game than there is to play some YouTube
guy had a early copy the game apparently
put up a five hour run and there's it's
not a lot of games like lying about half
of that was was cutscenes but but on the
developers responded saying that is not
actually the full game that's not a an
accurate representation of everything
that you're gonna be able to play yeah
and I mean we'll we'll have a full
answer pretty soon we have one of our
guys in the office Kevin or yes playing
the game right now yeah and I've gone by
to check it out every now and then but
at the same time I don't know that it's
that huge of a problem that it would be
a short game what do you think like if
it's good enough like sixty dollars for
a new release games the two language for
five hours if it's a five-hour game
that's really too much like telltale has
shell cell just like five dollars in
episode and you get like an hour and a
half and that i can see ya unlike the
whole series is what like 25 and you get
maybe went like six seven hours of a
play but i think sixty dollars for five
hours if that's true is like long it is
but it's a fact so as I mean as a
because I work in the industry I I
actually don't get a lot of games for
for free yes the mind work doesn't
actually involve a lot of gameplay yeah
I'd pay for my own games and I buy them
on Steam really cheap or I wait for them
to go on sale so for me it's usually
like a ten twenty dollar investment so
for me that that link doesn't matter as
much because I'm just gonna buy it when
it gets to that sweet spot like south
park at twenty bucks that was perfect
that's not super long game but twenty
bucks like totally worth it for a 15
hour 12 our experience and the thing
that sticks out to me with this is like
for instance my brother or folks who
don't play that many games every year
though he'll pick up a call of duty and
he'll pick it up on launch and it'll
cost you know sixty dollars and he
doesn't play multiplayer so basically
how he's playing a single player game
for sixty dollars so what do you think
why is it like when it comes to
something I call a duty were so many
people only play single player or so
many people only play multiplayer that
were like more forgiving there than we
might be with something like this it
only part of it is that that excitement
of playing that game even if you're not
playing it you know multiplayer with
friends but having that experience along
with everybody else like there's some
movies that I'm gonna go see in the
theater like I know it's not worth it if
I win a couple months I can just see it
on netflix or see it only like rented
from amazon online but sometimes it's
worth it just to be able to be a part of
those conversations with everybody else
until I [ __ ] like that part that
happened in that movie that was so cool
in games can be the same way but it's so
much of its a much bigger investment
like asking someone to say to spend
sixty dollars on day one and then spent
six hours or seven hours rather than the
one that this reminds me of actually is
have either the place spec ops the line
yes so spec ops was a not a long game
there was no multiplayer component to
speak of yeah and it wasn't the best
shooter in the world but it was one of
those games like you were saying Justin
that people were talking about and I
remember not picking up when I first
came out but it was so much buzz around
what that game was attempting to do with
its story that by the time it dropped
down to about 40 bucks I was like all
right I'm gonna give it a go and then I
felt like I had my money's worth what
what did you think when he played it i
don't know i see i thought the story was
very impactful it sort of reminds me of
I know that game was well it can aight
that's like an eight hour historians
backups I blew through bioshock infinite
in like 110 hours sitting watch eight
sixty dollars on lunch and I got it was
fine I did the same actually I was going
on holidays and have to complete it in
one night cuz I've almost boiling it was
the first but I thought that spec ops
the line was powerful enough that I
didn't really want to finish it I didn't
really think oh i just spent sixty
dollars and only got eight hours of
entertainment i really think about it in
that way so i think it has a lot to do
with i think what the game's trying to
do and how people take the content like
if you only have a single player story
and it's you know eight hours but it
does it does what it does really well to
engaged I think that's money well spent
but if it feels like it's you know
missing something that can understand
why people get upset about spending that
much and then we also have that
juxtaposed against gains that don't have
a story at all that are either sixty
dollars or in some cases free I spent
hundreds of hours in hearthstone and I
and I've paid a bit of money not not
sixty dollars worth but I I like seven
hundred or so I'm not keeping an eye on
another like 2,000 oh yeah but you know
that's something that has a lot of
gameplay weather regardless of how much
money put into it it's something that
you can take those
all parcels I'm never gonna sit and do a
attend our stretch from this gonna play
hearthstone for 10 hours but whereas
Bioshock that's something I will sit and
just don't run through the first time
and I've been played that one the second
time because i think wanted to do it the
harder difficulty both because i really
enjoyed the story and i want to get that
experience again but also to prove like
i can do it harder difficulty so like
how do you gauge how much gameplay there
is like is it if it's worth it to play
for a second time then it's suddenly
twice as long yeah we're down i guess
like the answer to this is the really
obvious answer is that if it's good
enough then yet the cash so to that
point the order 1886 how many you guys
played us do you think it's i obviously
the version that's in the office of the
moment cabins playing yeah none of us
have played that's under bra go anyway
have you played it at any events i have
what do you think cause i played it a
bunch i know how i feel better so
mention what you think person well you
and I had this conversation at the
PlayStation experience it was the same
every demo that I've played at the game
so far I feel like I can't pass judgment
on it because every demo I played is
some variation of cutscene and then a
close-quarters combat situation a
PlayStation experience they have you you
grapple down the side of the blue
balloon does everything and then you're
in a tight little little bit corridors
yeah like a house you're in a house and
you're shooting from the top and then
you're shooting from the bottom of yours
clearing enemies out of room and it's
still very very close yeah and then
another one you're in like a kitchen
that's sort of set up like a maze and
you're always you know this far away
from your enemy and I feel like I
haven't really gotten gotten enough time
to like explore with a game s to offer
right now I just see it as like a
hallway so I'm interested to see what
else there is that's like the problem of
vertical slices I gather we gotta do
their conferences but the problem that I
thought every time is it whenever I've
seen trailers others it makes it look
like a regular linear third person
action game and when I play this like
people are saying like oh it's like a
Gears of War type thing you know it's
like a year in a bit since the consoles
chronic come out and here's a really
good looking you know third person
actually but what I've played it it's
felt so on rails in comparison to any
third person action game like it makes
games like spec ops the sections that
I've played feel like like they're open
worlds like where you can like take
different angles and you know attack the
objectives in different ways whereas
whenever I play the
it's been like shoot gonna shoot that
guy now press triangle and do this thing
and look at this piece of inventory so
it feels a lot more like like heavy rain
like a bit more like a resident evil 6
i'm not in terms of like I don't say in
terms of quality because like that's
that's not what I'm getting up and in
terms of like here is a section of a
game play it the way it's meant to be
played if you don't you die go back to
the stars every demo I've played it felt
like that so like that's the worry like
I think third this week's gonna be
reducing when those reviews here yeah I
am interested to see what Kevin thinks
about I'm interested it try it out
myself I but like you said it's weird is
it's hard when you're only given a small
part of a game you're not able to really
experience all the different parts of it
and what we've seen that isn't
necessarily indicative of the whole game
we're also told like the same things
that everybody else hears there's a lot
more to it there's all these different
and like that's what we know about the
game and you know we hope we expect
different things but it is it's weird
that it's set up like a shooter when
what we played doesn't quite feel like
that I guess we'll find out pretty soon
as Thursday five a.m. Pacific is when
the embargo lifts on the order 1886 with
a review of on gamespot com that's 8
a.m. eastern yeah that should be a
pretty interesting we'll see we'll see
you later in a week how good that game
is let us know what you think in the
comments below all right folks the folks
from Bossa studios here to talk about
bread surgeons and a bunch more new
stuff they have up their sleeves but
first of all let's check out a trailer
for the new ps4 game hands of fate FTE
spell it
hello welcome back to the lobby I'm very
happy to be joined by the folks from
parts of studios Luke and Enrique do my
friends hey great to have you on the
show all the way over from London town
yes clean are you enjoying the weather
over here in the west coast of the
States yeah I think any book teaches
something I think he's always warmer oh
really well then here's California and
goes ask me lovely yeah and it wasn't
sunday and it's kind of going on yeah
it's gone back to sort of an early not
as bad as the rest of America we know
covered in snow yeah yeah I think this
is the only part of America that's not
covered on there like Twilight 50 feet
of snow was at MIT have like a helps of
MIT where they have like a three-story
pile of snow outside one of the
buildings yeah it's that it's pretty
ridiculous nationalist like that so for
the folks that who might not the word
boss the studios how the trigger is
something in their head but they don't
know who exactly why I tell us about
some of the games you've made slim
appoint my stone first legend simulator
and I am Brett moment yeah yeah and now
words adrift yes is one of the programs
are working on parallel to try and bread
yeah looking forward to talking to you
guys about that especially as it's sort
of it's a little bit difference to what
somebody's do so like surgeon simulator
was a game that came out sort of the
same way games like goat simulator have
where there's like this really
interesting initial hook and it like
Keeks people's interest and then they
see videos of the game and realize oh
there's actually quite a lot to this how
did it the game calm about how did you
come up with it that was global game jam
2013 I mean three other guys she went
Long's like a nearby college in london
and just kind of decided to go kind of
stupid make ourselves laughs cuz we were
going to be awake for hours right what
was the hook because it's usually like a
one-sentence like hook for a game jam
right that you have to like have like
yeah yes it's basically like a theme and
the theme of this that years was just
the sound of a heartbeat okay and we
went literal yeah that's really good go
oh and then the result was there was so
dissimilar yeah and and then it kind of
like the monday after the game download
literally like within 24 hours of
finishing it it kind of went all over
I was like YouTube and as always buzz
about and we had no idea like we yeah we
were taken completely by surprise the I
do as well right there's no idea we
stopped on the tracks and say okay stop
everything guys you know your projects
just get together and then let's pick
certain forward and then lady hold 48
days later we released on Steam that's
crazy yeah we did this 48 hours into 48
day yeah yeah yeah good segue there and
now look few weeks ago when we hit two
million kind of sales on I'm Sergeant
yeah just yeah so when you're doing the
game jams is it mostly just like flex
your muscles as a creative or do you
actually go into those thinking oh we
might end up coming out with something
like was it that surprising ya know to
game gems at the same we always try and
use new formats and new themes and new
constraints and new freedoms the only
thing we never did was anything goes
because when when we tried that once or
never did we did once the first one was
the first six games ends or so we didn't
came up like a little bit of restriction
sort of forces you out of your comfort
zone yeah get to get you get your
creativity but as good as that you we
work we look at home cheers we have
different kind of teams like the iron
bread team well the drift teams talking
about and the game jams are great could
you start working with different people
and they're like you don't really know
what's going to come out of it I mean
IIM bread was a year and a half after
kind of the whole surge and stuff yeah
we had 50 or 60 kind of game ideas in
between that time oh really that never
just may exactly yeah you kind of you
get a good feeling sometimes just from
the reaction from other people in the
studio and stuff when when a kind of
game is starting to kind of come
together so how did I impreza end up
being the game that you wanted to go go
with um it was we check out this hot
gameplay by of bread the physio to the
game jam last year and i found the idea
of like with certain we had like the one
task that we give you which is like
perform a heart transplant right really
simple easy to understand kind of wears
not really simple but it's easy to
understand and with iron bread i like
the idea of just a piece of bread who
would want to become toast that's it
like so every level you go into it's
like pecan toast and that's something
that kind of players to understanding
kind of get behind our then we just
messed around with trying to get
controls right see actual game jam was
just happy
that movement how do you how do you move
a bread around level but you can you can
control sticker then just use a to jump
right but then you're just replacing a
character with a piece of bread and
that's not very interesting yeah so the
whole kind of like four corners and
flopping it around those kind of you
know at the end of the game jam it kind
of worked and we saw it more like yeah
there's actually something there like I
think the key thing is something that
you can get good at like like surge and
everyone who prefers plays it is awful
yeah but then you see the speed runs and
the world records and these geysers
dextrous is like like it was a real hand
yeah I'm like you're saying before and
we it's a game that all of the controls
and all of what the player can do is
actually doable from the start of the
game it's not like you're leveling up or
like giving them new abilities or
anything no no sire it's really
satisfying yeah it's all on you you
progress as a player right and also the
other aspect is that you kind of 4shared
what you can do in the game well maybe
if I drop from that ledge or grab that
brick and throw into the car windshield
that can get inside of the car and when
you realize it can actually do that it's
such a busy such a good surprise and i
think the controls came out of debt as
well is the surprise of okay i can move
the bread around like very poorly like
this and all of a sudden you realize you
can flip and rotate and scale a nest on
general to understand the weight of the
Bretton yeah kind of sloppiness and they
can kind of like swing and wrap
themselves around like shelves and then
they can climb that way and it's yeah
it's this kind are you like masters of
QWOP is that oh I've no idea I don't
know we don't feel x terrible I just
thinking actually like most developers
have to explain to their parents like
how weird their job is like I work on
this thing on a like for you guys it's
actually quite a lot weirder yeah I made
a game where you get to control people
without I what kind of games you can get
like said you seem like I'm Breton ago
what's that and it's like oh you control
one hand yep presumably we're not tell
you made surgeon severe they think
you're making like medical research
software yeah that's a first reaction
people don't play again yep I'm all
right okay that's very nice for that we
actually got once I think it was a red
door Eurogamer someone from NHS stop by
oh yeah
they left the card and everything let's
get it a little late oh you want any
kind of like medical sort of like you
know advice or like Tom like consorting
right yeah patient and I I don't think
it's the right game for that that's
great I was talking to Armand when the
guys from at goat simulator and they
said that they had people reaching out
to them as goat experts yeah saying like
oh if you want I could consult with you
for a nominal fee unlike really
interesting things that I goat
apparently it's indicative of all of
games yeah I think it's member you
attach a similar to it right here and
some games like plague Inc I don't know
if you played that one and you know one
where you're simulating a plague bring
it across the world and they like they
tied in with the the CDC and like to get
that to be accurate afterward like I
think the game came out first and then
the CDC reach down like here's how we
can make this even more of a react
accurate simulation of this well it's
kind of dark that's your bowl of
expansion oh no no yes no no it's
earlier you're you're actually spreading
the disease that yeah you know fighting
yes no endemic would ya murder everyone
in the world yeah what the CBC who did
like a how fast and proper zombie
apocalypse would spread the right they
sound really they investigate in World
War Craft cos way back yeah I had the
virus then I yeah actually yeah but
someone took from a dungeon hmm and my
Unleashed it in the capital city even
they're almost dying and then yeah said
like I see is he already interested oh
how it spread and because it was kind of
like the first virtual disease spread
like we've kind of its weird games
getting into all sorts of interesting
areas and you guys have you ever like
been criticized for those games out
there that are clearly made for like oh
we're trying to get twitch and like
youtubers to play these games you know
let's come up with a zany idea like
something like meme Ron sort of pops
into mind where it's actually not very
good game at all and but it's like it's
clearly made for just people to play for
the sake of it and air control is
another one that came out last year did
you guys can get that a lot and he's
that good get for Bradley Roby surgeon
not because sin was one of the one of
the big ones who brought first ones yeah
yeah he's like kind of my sails out of
that kind of thing
than people you know yeah they set the
precedence but they're online Brad we
got a little bit of a flag saying that
our shows youtube bait and so on and it
took a while for the first let's place
to come out and people realize is
actually gameplay involved yeah because
that's how we start we started on core
gameplay and always the theme comes
afterwards yeah they're like two days to
make these games you don't have time to
no no in two days you can barely get
something working right if you have
throw all these requirements on top has
to be good for YouTube has to be a is
any idea who r & F with nothing yes ooh
maybe that's not the methodology of
taking the world's adrift like how is
this card game come out of the head of
your studio is it another game jam
situation yeah it was the game john
scott lee more ambitious game jam and
again it's taking that kind of physics
thing and and something that is a base
skill that doesn't change about the game
you can get really good at it is instant
it's very much like a i mean a Spider
Man esque like a rattling hook there's a
lot been very many kind of good spy my
there one really good one on the
playstation two ways they don't we go
yeah we had a look at that one because I
doesn't want everyone went to and went
that's how you do like swinging
mechanically we kind of look that when
it's got like inertia and all that kind
of stuff that feels really nice that we
we definitely look to that one but with
this you can assign miss you wherever
you attach and so if you can be swinging
for a forest and you can manually attach
a rope to every single branch and
because of the way we so it takes a
while to learn and better yet yeah like
you know like surgeon style and I'm
bread boy when you get really good at
you get really good at and we've seen
people like flinging themselves off of
their ships and launching on to someone
else's then taking them out that way
that's just a dis talking point because
the whole thing the whole game is
physics-based thanks to the chap that
improbable helping you out with the
lying angels but things like if you
attach four or five people to an engine
on a ship you can your weight is going
to rip it off and you can fling yourself
because the you can actually rotate you
can entangle though yeah they wrote me
right rats all wrapped around yes I feel
like some swinging you hit an object you
you kind of build up speak and suddenly
it's like one and and that's how I can
care for yourself or other things people
or even grappling hook to a propeller
that yoshinoya [ __ ] is like Harper
it's like one of their engines and yank
it clean offer than their ships kind of
flying all wonky thank you know the kind
of runs me a bit of Just Cause
multiplayer yeah that's not a good
really and they have really fun with
that sort of stuff yeah I'm the game
itself it seems much more serious than
some of your other games that I'm sure
other people you know look at surgery
yeah as in-depth as those can be surgeon
simulator dying breath they're kind of
silly but it seems like you guys
actually learned a lot from those that
you're able to bring to this yeah it's
it's just it's a big a game for sure but
we have moments of silliness like
because we're like swinging around we
love our kind of physics and stuff like
if you swing yourself into a rock or
into a tree branch or cat door get
knocked down guys dangle there on the
rope so you're kind of left like one or
a ball and that kind of sauce fun to do
but yeah I mean in the grand scheme of
things it sir it's you kind of gathering
a crew if you want and you all kind of
invest yourself in this one shipped
yelled and you build the ships as well
yeah you build the ships then you can
basically just you fly off to the
different kind of those islands its kind
of wind waker skies of arcadia inspired
and blue you see their silhouettes in
the distance you like i want to go there
and then you can kind of traverse
through kind of weathers and storms not
see you can run into other players who
may attack or may not attack you and
stuff like yeah there's a lot of
emergent gameplay as well which is a
hallmark of both their Adam surgeon and
we we have no idea how the players are
going to interact and create the rules
how how they going to board another ship
what tactics they will come up with yeah
destroy their engines and take over
their shapes itself is that's what we
hope for people using the game that we
created to make stuff that we cannot
imagine that you'd be done looking the
latest play test where you on a ship
kind of firing another one and one of
the players from that [ __ ] was like I've
got takeout him three he swung down
swung onto the ship without him
realizing grabbed another can on the
deck and then just clean just shot him
in the cannon went flying off cuz you're
kind of touch to these little like see
it or toes and hence the count went
flying off the edge of the ship and then
that was it like you take out the threat
oh yeah Billy Meza built about horrible
definitely the three ships firing any
time as budget like we knew had no idea
you could really do that no we never
knew that it could be done yeah we do
the [ __ ] should also you like kind bits
with attached but when someone went and
just grabbed another toy on the same
ship and went boom just fight it at the
deck is that like an important thing for
you guys in terms of like get you've
always been very good at getting your
games out to people so like what surgeon
when surgeon came out you actually add
loads of stop to it
but presumably based on some feedback
you got from the community and I am
bread is the same situation you've still
got a team working on it right now yeah
have you taken like that similar
methodology worlds drift because i
remember the first trailer you put out
was very much a like let us know what
you think come players and should this
be an idea that we go with you know are
you listening to the gears how much do
you listen to community we have to
listen farm or what everything that went
a lot of the server went in certain in a
lot of stuff that going into bread right
now comes from the community they asked
for outlets but let's put the the
bagasse a mms but the free roaming mode
they asked it a lot for that but they
are smaller games we can see the
beginning of the game and visualize it
and say it's a good game you put a video
out people get interested in we carry on
development and early access to lemon
but with words adrift is different
because such a good such a huge
enterprise so we have to do that for
form from the beginning and he's already
paying off i think that this for the
third video we put up we focus on a
little bit on gathering resources and
crafting yeah yeah it's not the the core
of the game at all but who was an aspect
of the game we just finished doing so we
showed up and people didn't enjoy it as
much as the rest of the game yeah yeah
well laterz be my all now it's just
another survival game yeah right yeah i
don't we have none of the like taking
care of your character like feeding them
we're not interested in that it's it's
like kind of preserving your your
airship in a way and making sure you can
kind of keep on flying yeah but that's
in informed us to say okay we need
crafting and we need gathering but this
is enough now we move on to other stuff
yeah more interesting and so on so the
measuring those reactions from people's
not like they are telling us what to do
but they are guiding our hand in which
we travel with focus on it's so much
better to do that way then release a
gaming realize that we did so many
mistakes along the way once it's at them
it's almost too late or near exactly
yeah address those issues and so for
folks for watching I who wants to get in
and play it as early as possible and I
felt like a sign up on your website like
yeah how can they get in an extra buck
was drift calm we have you can email
sign up or whatever just keep tabs on
now we have like a blog post every week
nope i'm releasing new information and
stuff are then eventually when we do get
to cause some clothes days and stuff
will kind of scent that few invites and
kind of get people into their yeah i'm
not going far we would like to do things
as early as four
what form we filled up from this whole
thing that lets get a feedback so any
idea when we'll get a closed beta or
open beta so same again this year
there's definitely amazing actually I
probably did the first half of the year
yeah do you think you would ever
combined the world so that as you're
going through worlds adrift you would
see like a little pieces like go into a
k20 the first movement I'll be
incredibly naughty that isn't any kind
of surgeon or bread references right at
some point you're going to shave like
the bossa universe yeah yeah
everything's fighting together yeah
including like your old facebook games
are all existing yeah well yeah yeah
yeah those are very very early on
excellence at labs thank you very much
loopy I could have very pleasure thank
you so much lebanon at best not so we
look forward to seeing more of our was a
Jif throughout the rest for 2015 yes
thank you awesome thanks everyone for
watching lobby this week if you have any
feedback as ever please put it in the
comments below and next week hopefully
we're gonna talk a bunch about the order
1886 yo never forget I'm gonna get a
tattooed in like gothic script on my
inside of my arm and be like yeah that's
that's the centenary before I was born
yeah don't worry it's we're not live it
to the matter at thanks it what today
we're good we're good to go Mary right
alright let's wrap this [ __ ] up have a
great week everyone and we will see you
next week tuesday 2 p.m. pacific right
here on the lobby take care
you